hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar introduction to ai image
analysis of microscopy i'm susie valdez
of labyrinths and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by leica
microsystems to learn more visit them at
leica hyphenmicrosystems.com
now i want to encourage you to
participate today by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or curing this
presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our presenter
dr quinn tran an applications and
marketing manager at avia dr tran
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody welcome to the webinar
and thank you very much for joining us
today my name is quinn tran and today
i'll be doing an introduction to ai
image analysis and microscopy
a quick look at our agenda
we're going to go through some ai basics
and then specifically machine learning
and how it can be applied in the
microscopy field we'll then talk about
deep learning and how that is applicable
and then do a q a session so that you
have plenty of time to ask me questions
about
the topics that they covered here and
potentially how these tools and
applications can be utilized in your
particular research
so some overall terminology to kind of
lay the foundation for us here so
artificial intelligence or ai as you
probably have heard it is software that
mimics the way we humans think and learn
machine learning is a subcategory of
this that is specifying algorithms that
don't explicitly
that hasn't been explicitly programmed
to complete a particular task they
however learn to do this task from
training data i hope that's going to be
a little bit clearer as we talk more
about machine learning and i showcase
some examples for you
now another
smaller and even more subgroup of this
is deep learning and deep learning
really expands and allows the software
to learn from a large and vast amount of
images and data and information to
complete the task
at hand
a quick look at how traditional versus
ai based image analysis workflow
is done so in traditional image analysis
workflow we humans tend to
we humans create the rules
and feed these rules and the data into
the program so some examples of rules
that could be created is
that a cell has to be a certain level of
intensity and a certain size to be
counted and we feed these rules and the
data into a program and the program
provides us with answers so
um segmentation and detection of the
cells that we wanted
now with machine learning we're
basically flipping that around and what
we're actually putting into the
framework is answers and data so answers
could be examples of what a cell looks
like examples of what a protein looks
like
and we're feeding the the examples and
the data into the network and the
framework here and what it provides us
are the rules the rules that govern um
and
characterize why the cell is unique why
it's different from the background why
it's different from
the other cells or the other protein
that you can look for um that are in
your image essentially so it's a
collection of rules that really help us
characterize
our unique objects that we're trying to
detect
so let's dive into machine learning and
how it can be used in microscopy and
particularly i'm talking about the
random force algorithm this
algorithm is one of the most commonly
used algorithms when it comes to machine
learning in microscopy
you probably have already seen it
used in ways to as a way to classify
pixels or objects into different classes
and different groups
and essentially it's composed of
multiple decision trees here that
collectively allows the software and
allows you to
select or or classify each pixel or each
object
now let's dive into what is a decision
tree it's a type of supervised learning
and it's essentially create a created
and composed of a number of features
that are critical to making um a
decision or a classification
so the example i have here is somebody
coming in to apply for a loan and some
of the key features and key metrics that
the person who's um the loan officer may
look at is the age you are your
education level whether or not you're a
homeowner and the amount of income you
bring in and these features help the the
loan officer essentially decide whether
to refuse this loan or to provide you
the credit so this is one decision tree
composed of these set of features to
provide a way to classify this
particular application
now in the learning process itself each
of these features essentially gets a
vote and the majority of the voting of
these features determines the
classification
and the output of this particular tree
and what we're really trying to
accomplish with the decision trees is to
group and
create a set of features that allows us
to
to best categorize and best split the
data so we're looking and trying to
determine a set of features that really
allow us to classify whether this is a
cell or not a cell
and so how do we get from a decision
tree to a random force and essentially
the overall workflow is we take the
entire data set with the labels the
examples of what the cell looks like and
then we subdivide this data into random
groups and random subsets of the data
we utilize this to teach a tree and each
of these trees also have a random
selection of features so this tree is
going to have a unique set of data
points and unique set of features to
allow us to make that classification of
a cell or not a cell
and then essentially we repeat this
process to create our random force and
the goal here is that because it's a
random selection of data points and
features that make each of these cell
each of these trees each of these trees
are going to be slightly unique from one
another it's going to be looking at
slightly different things with slightly
different data and collectively this
decision tree and this random force is
going to allow us to come to the right
answer of whether or not this is a cell
versus a background or a different class
of cell so you can see here where the
the name and the terminology comes from
right you're you're creating a force of
decision trees that are kind of randomly
created hence the name the random forest
algorithm that's kind of my easy way to
think about this and an easy way to
remember um this algorithm
now how does this get applied in person
um we really just talked about kind of
the theory behind it but how do you
actually use it in microscopy data set
so this is an example of what a machine
learning pixel classifier training could
look like so here we creating a
model that has two classes what we want
in the background and we're providing
examples of each of these two classes by
essentially painting the pixels which
pixels really characterize what it is
that we want to detect and then which
pixels characterize that background
class so again we're painting examples
of these two classes
during our training process
and then we create a random forest
algorithm that allows us to basically
classify each of these pixels
from for one of the classes so we
basically get an output once we apply
once we create the model and apply the
model that classifies pixel by pixel is
it background or is it what we wanted
and you can see with just a a small set
of example pixels that we provide to the
random force algorithm we can
a we can basically classify the rest of
the image into these two classes and it
does a relatively good job about picking
up what it is that we want and what it
is that we we classify as background now
this example only has two classes
however you can make additional classes
with the pixel classifier
now a few more examples of of what image
enhancement using the machine learning
algorithm could look like so this left
example here is extracting multiple
structures from a single channel so here
we have a protein or a marker that
essentially has stained both the nucleus
and the cell membrane in relatively
the same level of intensity so if we
were to apply a intensity
based algorithm here it would be really
difficult to kind of divide and separate
these two components however as you know
human beings as we look at this we can
extract the other morphological
characteristics from it right the
nucleus is more globular circular where
the cell membrane is more straight and
thin
and so essentially we can use the pixel
classifier to take advantage of some of
those more morphological characters the
characteristics that i just kind of
described in words
um and paint examples of what the
nucleus looks like what the cell
cytoplasm looks like and then what the
cell membrane looks like and divide and
go from essentially one single channel
to three
three channels the blue purple for the
cell nucleus the red for the cell
cytoplasm and the yellow for the cell
membrane so now we have this
fluorescent-like image that separates
these three components that we can now
further do subsequent analysis such as
calc cell counting detection things like
that
we also have the ability with the
machine learning algorithm to go from a
heterogeneous staining to a more um
homogeneous name so in this particular
example and you can see a little bit
more in in the larger nucleus that this
um
this nuclear staining is heterogeneous
and has a kind of more puncta appearance
where there are areas of bright
intensity in areas of low intensity and
this again would be really difficult to
capture the more the the whole nucleus
if we were just using an intensity
intensity based algorithm so what we did
here is we provided examples of what the
entire nucleus looks like and the pixel
classifier kind of expanded this and
allowed us to create a
a new channel that has um a more
homogeneous staining and evens out the
staining and captures the full
scope of the nucleus so that subsequent
image analysis protocols that we have
that are intensity based can now do a
much better job at this detection
and then the example we saw with the
training is that we have the ability to
enhance certain objects of interest
from the the the image that you have um
created
we can also go from a phase to a more
fluorescent like image
as some of you may have tried to kind of
do this in your face contrast image
intensity-based algorithms again here
are really difficult because there's not
as much
contrast between the cell and the
background in terms of intensity but if
we
use the pixel classifier we can use some
of the more morphological
characteristics and pull that out and
really create this fluorescent-like
image that has a high intensity level
for the the cell and a low intensity
level for the background so that wide
range and that variation really allows
us to now do detection and analysis with
intensity-based algorithms later on and
it makes that process a lot easier
there are always there are also ways and
tools that can allow you to go from the
pixel classifier from the image using
the pixel classifier to go from the
image all the way to image all the way
to the segmentation not just an
enhancement but all the way to
segmentation
and the examples i provide here are one
segmenting cells in particular for this
example the nucleus and the histology
image and also the ability to segment
cells in phase contrast image to perhaps
help you do cell counting a little
quicker and a little bit easier
and to also segment cells and
fluorescent based images and i really um
like using machine learning for
um
cell detection of cells that are kind of
uh elongated or have a
very unique structure to them a lot of
the algorithms that are traditionally
used that are commonly used um are
optimized for more kind of globular
cells which makes it a little bit tricky
if your your cells don't kind of conform
to that morphology so the pixel
classifier kind of allows you to expand
that a little bit more and capture some
morphology that are elongated or just
kind of irregular
um i also
excuse me i also uh really enjoy using
the pixel classifier the machine
learning algorithms in general to
segment and to detect cells that are
kind of
really difficult to partition based on
intensity levels
and
the the machine learning algorithm just
again allows me to take that step
further so that i can separate these
cells more based on more than just
intensity and cell size
it allows me to add a lot more
complexity to that so that partitioning
is significantly um better
so some key advantage that i hope you've
seen from from the examples i provided
here
machine learning really allows you to
leverage your biological expertise here
you are the one that's kind of providing
the expertise and providing the examples
of the objects that you don't want and
what makes kind of the class that you
you want
um
and then because you're you're providing
these examples through a painting method
um it cuts down and reduces the
knowledge of computer science that's
required in terms of image analysis and
in terms of using machine learning
it allows you to kind of again utilize
your biological knowledge to provide
those examples instead of those rules
that
that may be required
and may utilize discrete measurements
that you have to figure out
um and it allows you to kind of go
beyond those discrete measurements right
to characterize your objects and go from
difficult
images to analyze and making them easier
to analyze so even if you do have to use
an intensity based algorithm later on
you can make those
images a little bit easier for the
algorithms to to process and to analyze
so you can you know kind of have the
best of both worlds pixel classifier
machine learning to make it a little bit
easier and then the the intensity
intensity-based algorithms that you're
more familiar with and used to and have
developed a pipeline um to process the
rest of the the images
to process the images the rest of the
way
so now let's kind of shift gears a
little bit and talk about deep learning
and microscopy particularly the
convolution neural network um and this
neural network is is really commonly
used um in in
ai in deep learning in relationship to
the microscopy field and essentially the
structure of it is it's composed of
input layers
and hidden layers and then these hidden
layers can range in
in numbers quite a bit
um and then an output layer and i hope
that you'll be able to see um a little
bit when i show you the next video is
that
this network really kind of resembles
and
uh
mimics the way
neurons work within our brain especially
how they signal and they signal to one
another
so this video is kind of gonna it's
gonna walk you through some of the
basics of what a convolution neural
network is and also introduce you to
some key terminology that you may have
seen in this literature
so
what
out
so
what i showed you is just a brief
glimpse of of this
field of research and researchers
continue to push the boundaries of what
machine what deep learning can do for
microscopy data sets by developing new
types of architectures i'm just
providing some examples you may have
seen before you net our canned care to
kind of
utilize deep learning for a number of
applications in microscopy there are
also a number of researchers who are
looking to different types of networks
to again push that boundary of deep
learning and microscopy so i won't be
able to cover everything here so i
really um encourage you to kind of
explore this a little bit more there's a
lot of really groundbreaking and
exciting work that's happening in this
field that is um really taking the next
steps between what we can do
in terms of microscopy in terms of
visualization and analysis and really
taking it to the next level so i highly
encourage you to look into this a little
bit more
now let's talk about and let's kind of
see deep learning in action
so let's go back to kind of what deep
learning could look like and usually
looks like so it usually starts out with
what we call an input image pair this
particular example is a low signal to
noise image and a high signal to noise
image as this pair and it essentially
gets fed into a neural network and this
neural network can be
different depending on
what it is that you're looking for to do
and what works kind of best for your
data and essentially all this output uh
in is a deep learning train model so
it's that set and collection of rules
that we talked about earlier and this
allows you to now add in more data and
apply this model to create
in this particular case a restored image
so this workflow in this model is really
created to take a low signal to noise
image and turn it into a high signal to
noise image so that's why when you apply
the model here you get this restored
image
i also want to briefly show you what
this could look like for em segmentation
um just because the image pair here is
gonna be slightly different we're
looking at the original data and the
annotated or the segmentated results
that you have again we feed this into a
particular model and we get a trained
model which now we can input new em data
and typically what this creates for you
is a confidence map
and the reason why it's called a
confidence map is that each of these
pixels the intensity of it correlates to
how confidence the software is that this
is your object of uh interest so if it's
really confident that intensity is going
to be really high if it's less
confidence that intensity is going to be
really low so that's kind of the one of
the reasons why the terminology
confidence map is used here
so some examples of what that could
actually of deep learning could look
like in microscopy so one example here
i'm going to show you is denoising so
essentially the image pair that we input
into the into the model is a low signal
to noise image and the ground truth
which is this high signal to noise image
we create a model and then we apply
it to new data and this is the restored
output of this
model and in this particular case we're
using a 3d arcane data set
so
hello
so
this paper has now been published in
nature methods so that file archive
references is a little bit outdated
um another application that we can
utilize deep learning for is commonly
referred to as virtual painting and in
this particular case what the model does
is it takes in a bright field um like
image and essentially predicts
where
and where the location of certain um
components of the cells are so here
we're looking at the nucleus the actin
and the microtubule so we're going from
a bright field and predicting where
these three components are for each
individual cells that is located here in
the image so it's kind of like that that
conversion between bright fields and and
fluorescent um like image with all of
these three components
another application for deep learning is
automatic uh segmentation and em images
in this particular case what we're
segmenting are neurons in this em data
set
um and once the confidence map is
created uh we can we can utilize it to
create these morphological meshes of
what the neuron surface looks like and
from there also create those center line
to allow you to look at complex networks
a little bit better and with the
morphological surfaces kind of allow you
to see how the neuron dendrites kind of
enter
interact face kind of like um
directly and things like that so this
allows you to kind of go from em to
these meshes and result automatically
so some key advantage that i hope that
you've seen with the examples i provided
here is the ability to increase cell
viability and this one is really well
highlighted in that denoising method um
denoising model because you can take a
low signature noise uh
image that allows you to really preserve
your cell viability and your cell
viability over a long period of time but
transform it and and create a restored
image that really allows you to capture
the complexity and that crisp image that
you may need to answer some of your
biological questions and to do your
further
analysis another key advantage is
automatically
creating on an automated that should say
automated um automating difficult um
tasks and time consuming tasks this is
really highlighted by that em model um
where now lots of labs kind of go in and
manually draw these em and trace their
cells now we can apply a deep learning
model to really do this automatically it
allows you to kind of
enormously enormously increase your
output because you can you no longer
need to kind of sit there and do this
manually you can kind of
apply the model overnight over the
weekend and come back to results really
quickly
and then the last key advantage i want
to highlight is expanding the utility of
your microscope and this is really
highlighted by the virtual painting
model so taking a bright field image
again that gives you a scope that might
be a microscope that's that might be
easier for you to access or you really
need that type of system to keep your
cells viable
and really take that image and transform
it and create and predict something that
allows you to again
really delve into the complexity and
really allows you to answer some of
those research questions that you're
thinking of without sacrificing
um some of the cell viability and and
some of the microscopes that you may
have at hand that are readily available
to you
so some key summaries of ai and aia
microscopy overall
you provide examples instead of the
rules you provide examples of what the
cells look like what a good image looks
like
what the segmentation results could look
like instead of the rules that govern
those those key activities and those key
detections
it allows you to add complexity and
iteration into your analysis that really
allows you to expand beyond some
discrete measurements and really allows
you to tackle some of the more
challenging analysis and challenging
images that you may have created
and it can be utilized both for image
enhancement and image analysis you can
also even combine these two components
to really have a full workflow that is
um ai based or you can also combine it
with other techniques that are
kind of already optimized for your lab
and your images and really take
advantage of ai to help you along the
way
so with that i just wanted to mention
that if you've been really curious about
any of the applications i showcased
today i do highly recommend that you go
and request your avia trial
it's free and the applications and the
videos i showed you today was created in
avia so we do have the tools um in terms
of machine learning and deep learning
that you saw today just a brief
highlight because i missed some things
in terms of the artificial intelligence
capability in avia so we talked about
machine learning and we talked a lot
about the pixel classifier but avia also
has object classification that's really
driven by the machine learning deep uh
random force algorithm
um deep learning here the models that i
showed you um in avia we have already
created these models so they're
pre-trained so you can really
immediately use them for your
application so we have that image
restoration denoising that i spoke of
the image segmentation and the virtual
staining one that i didn't get to cover
is the image resolution model which
allows you to essentially go from a
confocal image to a higher resolution
image so again really allowing you to
perhaps improve your cell viability or
really take advantage of the utility of
the microscope that you have at hand
while still obtaining the information
that you need for further work
so with that i want to say thank you
very much for for attending i hope that
was very useful and informative and now
i'm i'm happy to take any questions that
you have again thank you very much
and thank you dr tran for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of the screen and we'll
answer as many as we have time for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in from our audience dr tran
what are the computer requirements for
using ai tools
oops we cannot hear you you're going to
have to unmute
sorry can you hear me now yep perfect
thank you excellent um so one of the key
components in terms of computers that
you need is a good graphics card
specifically because it's going to
utilize a lot of the gpu to do the
processing and the learning
now the machine learning piece requires
a little bit less
while the deep learning requires a lot
more capabilities there are also
some systems that are set up to take in
multiple graphics cards so again that
ability is going to kind of speed things
up and make things a little bit easier
from kind of a consumer perspective if
you want to get started a really nice
place to start is kind of some of the
requirements for
gaming laptops essentially that's kind
of where i started using a gaming laptop
specifically because they're really put
together and organized so that it's got
a very very nice graphics card on there
because computer games require quite a
bit of that processing so that's that's
a really good place to start
if you visit our avia webpage we also
have a section that has system
requirements and lists out some specific
key components you need including which
graphics card we recommend
thank you so much and dr chan when does
someone use a machine learning versus
deep learning
so that's a really great question and um
that varies quite a bit depending on
what you're you're doing so the
some of the
you know advantage and and disadvantage
here is
machine learning is
a lot easier to kind of get started so
as we kind of saw in the training all
you really need to do is paint examples
so you can essentially use any of the
existing image that you have to paint
examples with deep learning if there are
not pre-trained models that work out for
you it's likely that you need to create
additional data to train and augment
that model or to build your own model
completely from scratch so it is going
to require you to take a little bit more
time at the beginning to generate the
model that you need
my recommendation is that if you kind of
want to get started right away
i would say try the pixel classifier in
the object classifier using machine
learning because again that barrier to
entry is significantly lower and if that
doesn't work then we kind of move on to
deep learning that's probably the best
strategy
to begin with
thank you so much dr tran now how about
images how many images are required for
the training
so again there's there's quite a bit of
variation here and it really depends on
what it is you're looking for and
um how different they are
so from the machine learning and deep
learning perspective the clearer the
distinction between what you're looking
for in the background or cell a versus
cell b
the less examples that you will need
for the machine learning again i'm
talking about that
that picture that video where we're
painting and training you can see that
most of the time the machine learning
doesn't require as
much of the data as as we need
so it's just providing select regions of
of what the objects look like
for the deep learning it depends on what
you're doing and again what it is that
you're looking for the denoising model
that you saw
was created by 10 image pairs so
basically we fed pairs of
low signal to noise and high signal to
noise and there are 10 of those sets the
em segmentation gets a lot more complex
and takes a lot more data so it varies
quite a bit
and i highly suggest again kind of as a
starting point use that machine learning
piece to get started and then if you're
looking to move to deep learning take a
look around to see if anybody's already
created a model that is what it is that
you're looking for and what you're
trying to find really here is to match
the images that you've already created
to what they're using to train the model
and if it's a really good match it's
likely that you can use that pre-trained
model so you don't have to train your
own
thank you so much dr tran and again i
want to thank our audience for these
great questions coming in
our next audience member asks does a
random
forest algorithm only look at a single
pixel information or also an example
like neighborhood or whole object size
so the answer here is it looks at all of
that um so there are
what you create the feet how the
features is created is um through a set
of um
algorithms that take a look at pixel
information how two pixels relate to
each other how three pixels relate to
each other and it builds and builds that
layer so it looks at basically
everything like that for the object
classifier
it looks specifically at your meshes so
it takes in the whole object but the
pixel classifier also builds that
hierarchy and generates not only pixel
specific data but also kind of
neighborhood
and and city like uh features so so it's
a wide range whether it uses all that
information to build your random forest
is slightly different it's going to use
whatever is best to classify your data
that could be just you know how two
pixels relate to each other or that
could be how the entire cell relates to
the next cell so it varies quite a bit
in what gets pulled out eventually but
it does take a look at everything
thank you so much now dr tran what
features do you use for random forest
now this is this is kind of a broad
selection
and i have to be honest i don't know
which one i use at the top of my head
purely from the perspective that with
avia um which is the the software i'm
currently using to do the processing and
what i
used to showcase the examples here we do
have a set of default features that we
use
and this is for cells versus kind of
straight line
objects and things like that so there's
already kind of pre-programmed sets that
we use and i don't know what those
specific features at the top of my head
looks like i can email that out later
but there is a wide range of features
that
you can use a lot of it
if you're using a tool that's common
that's already kind of pre-built for you
in terms of machine learning those
features tend to be already programmed
in for you if you really kind of want to
go in and tweak um which features you
use they usually have the ability to do
that but most of the time people do tend
to set a certain number of defaults for
you so that you can at least get started
with the process um again i can go into
more details and then email later but i
don't know that's on top of my head
of course thank you so much our next
question can you briefly explain what is
the advantage of our can compared to
unit
uh
so this is going to be a slightly
very
it's going to be a complex um
answer and again probably something we
want to cover a little bit more my email
just because i can send you articles for
reference and things like that but
overall the u-net basically kind of has
a has a u-net structure and it's really
good and it's been widely used for
segmentation
segmentation kind of like the neuron um
applique neuron segmentation that we
have that's been kind of the unet
structure and that's the one that's
really widely used in that application
rkn tends to work um better when we're
talking about the denoising application
it's very popular there so the the
structure is different but it's really
um from from a user perspective it's
really about which one works best for
the application and that's kind of been
generally how it's been divided of
course the unet structure also can be
used for kind of the denoising
application it's um it's
used for both it's one of the first kind
of architectures that was uh widely used
so it's it's used for everything but in
avs case we really um have tailored it
to the segmentation portion versus the r
can that is for denoising but again
there's a lot of details here that i can
provide via email
thank you so much dr tran we have time
for one more question you showed a
confidence map which looks a lot like a
confidence interval
that a given pixel is statistically
correlated with each component extracted
does the underlying algorithm utilize
principal component analysis
so in avs particular case we do not do
that we do not use a pca however i've
seen lots of other works that takes an
additional step forward and utilizes
that particular the the pca principle to
do further processing um so no it in
this case it does not
dr tran thank you very much for your
presentation would you like to provide
any closing remarks for our audience
before we go
of course um i just again want to kind
of reiterate um a big thank you for
everybody who's attended i hope that
this was really informative for you and
you know there's a lot left here to
cover this is just i feel like the bare
minimum to kind of get us started so i
really highly recommend for anybody
who's doing some challenging data
analysis and challenging visualization
to try out some of these tools and to
try out ai because they've seen a lot of
amazing work come out of that
there's also a ton of literature out
there so this is just the flavor if you
want to you know start to to explore it
a little bit more there's there's lots
left to to do
and especially on the deep learning side
there's a lot of capabilities that are
still being explored so
i think for the next five to ten years
we'll see some really exciting work come
out in terms of ai in application to the
microscopy field so be on the lookout
it's it's going to be really exciting
and again just thank you for
for attending and thank you labyrinth
for kind of putting all of this together
well thank you dr tran again for your
time today and for your important
research and i also want to thank lab
roots and our sponsor leica microsystems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and before we go i want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted on the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand laborats
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone stay
safe bye